i will not talk about mastering
commander today besides what i just said
although i really want to continue the
streak of always talking about a sequel
with you
i would love that you know let's do it
what is it going to take for now
it's joking um listen about a year ago
you told me
at sundance that one division the
scripts were
unlike anything you had seen and you
couldn't wait for people to see it and
now that i've seen three episodes
i completely get what you're saying or
what you said back then
um what what has this thing been like
because it
or i guess if you could talk a little
bit about the fact that this series is
so
unlike anything that marvel has done
before i think that's right and i think
that
it's going to marvel fans when you get
to the end
what i am hoping for the show is that it
brings in new fans i think there's
some wonderful homages to tv shows
throughout the american century and also
uh i think that it's going to be
incredibly satisfying
for died in the world marvel fans
because you will get to look at the mcu
in a whole new light
i mean it of course starts with one
division with wonder and vision
dropped into a sort of idyllic black and
white
1950s suburban town and realizing
they're in a
a a you know a um a show
and then we start hurting through the
century
decade by decade at breakneck speed uh
episode by episode week by week and and
until vision begins to really realize
something's not right about something's
not right about this town
and then the world the mcu that we've
all grown to know and love and this
world
collide in the most epic
of endings and i will i
i i mean the stuff that i can't talk to
you about like
i get to work with this actor that is a
total secret and i get to work with this
actor that i have been
longing to work with and act with for
years
and i finally got to and it was amazing
and uh and fireworks
exploded and uh it was great
one of the things that people will
forget is that this all started with you
doing the voice over
role uh as the voice of a computer and
then
lo and behold it is now what it is how
early on did you
learn what the ultimate arc was or where
this was
all gonna go were you even was this even
hinted to you at the beginning
oh no no i didn't know that no and i
don't think they knew that about
me either i mean i think what happened
was
uh i solved a lot of problems
when they had spent a lot of money
trying to solve stuff in camera clarity
issues
and then tried to solve it with cg and
they still couldn't solve it i could
just go
the bad guys are coming on your left sir
and they would go oh my god i think
god we finally you know they've been
living with this problem for
whatever six months of editorial and uh
and
and i would you know we we all laughed
together
a lot and and
i think that when they came to hey what
about
vision and then they went hey what about
paul just because
i've been so pleasant to be around
i think they were doing me a favor uh i
already got to stop i'm just gonna say i
really can't wait to see where this all
goes
um and i wish you nothing but the best
thank you so much mate
thank you